[موسيقى]
ما هو دور الوحدة في رأيي في
جعل الناس معًا
لديهم نفس المشاعر إذا ذهبت إلى هناك ،
يجب أن يمنحك الشعور بالوحدة
مع الله. تركيا موطن لبعض من
أجمل المساجد وأكثرها شهرة في العالم
ولكن  في
العقدين الماضيين ، شهدت البلاد
فورة في بناء المساجد مع ظهور أماكن عبادة جديدة في
جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، وهي تتراوح من الصغيرة إلى
الكبيرة ، لكن العديد منها يشترك في تصميم مشابه جدًا.
يعود الطراز الذي يعود إلى القرن السادس عشر
والأكبر وربما الأكثر
إثارة للإعجاب بالقرب من مسجد عثماني هو أحد
المنافسين في اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
الكلاسيكي الجديد جون دانيلز من بين ما لدينا: حسن
حفظ الموز لدينا طبخ الكاميرا.
أطلق Boone LaRue Yuma النار على
إيريك ، ماذا تنسق في سونوما ،
سيدي ، قال إن تيلمان منجم وقال
إن المستمع الحديث
انجذب إلى هناك  ومع
ذلك ، أعتقد أن هذا التركيز المتجدد على
المساجد الكلاسيكية الجديدة يتعلق أكثر
بالسياسة والروحانية ، هناك
بالتأكيد تسييس
لعملية بناء المساجد ، أعتقد أنها
إحدى الوسائل التي يمكن للحكومة
من خلالها الترويج لموقعها
الريادي في العالم الإسلامي على ما يبدو
كما تعلم مع هذا
النوع الجديد من الهندسة المعمارية ، فإن
النهج العام هو الأكبر كلما كان ذلك أفضل ،
وأعتقد أن هناك الآن طلبًا شائعًا
لإعادة الاتصال بالماضي الإمبراطوري المجيد الذي
واجهه هذا المد من التصميم العثماني القريب ،
وقد غير بعض مهندسي المساجد
المسار بما في ذلك
مسجد سنجق لا الحائز على جائزة في
ضواحي اسطنبول كان سان جاكوار
مثالاً ومن ثم كان مثالًا
إيجابيًا لمن يريد أن يفعل شيئًا
ليس نسخة طبق الأصل ، إنه جو بسيط المظهر
ولكني أعتقد أن هناك
هالة معينة في  هذا الجزء الداخلي
ولا يوجد أي زخارف كبيرة ، ولا يوجد
ضوء قوي للغاية ، حيث يأتي ضوء من
جدار القبلة من الأب.  om شارع
جدار القبلة الزخرفة الوحيدة
للمبنى هي النور في رأيي
ستجد أنه لا يوجد أي
تعريف في أي كتابات إسلامية أو
حتى في القرآن عن شكل
مسجد كان من دواعي سروري أن
أكتشفه  أعتقد أن هذا الفضاء
يجهزك بطريقة ما لتكون وحيدًا مع الله